wer ist nochmal thomas d oder -defizite
änderte unsere top prominenten gäste
stellt er alle in den schatten
unglaublich dass frage video mit
mehreren zehntausend abrufen tausende
kommentare
bald 100 video fragen an ihn so was aber
noch nicht erlebt und da haben wir uns
deshalb was überlegt mit chrome zusammen
und zwar wir wollen einem dieser
wahnsinns konkret etwas ganz besonderes
bieten es war ein meet and greet unter
allen abonnenten
könnt ihr mitmachen können unter dieses
video gepostet was ist im moment also
meist entsorgt game von comte er das
richtig beantwortet dann habt ihr die
chance dabei zu sein und daraus wählen
wir einen aus also ich glaube wir müssen
nicht lange überlegen und ansonsten im
vorfeld das ist etwas wo ich nicht
gekommen sagen
haben aber
schon mal die mein bruder hat unser
frage beantworten weshalb die ich immer
so schön sagen stay tuned
achtet immer mal wieder rein ungesellig
zu verfassen